we don't know many details about the
colin kaepernick and eric reid collusion
grievance settlements but there is one
thing that we can glean from the way
that settlements typically happen
typically there is a provision a very
broad provision that will waive any and
all claims that were made or that could
have been made by the party who is
receiving some sort of a payment in
settlement of those claims meaning that
for Eric Reid specifically any claim
that he was the target of non-random
random PE detesting that there was any
type of foul play going on there that
there was anything being done by the NFL
to harass him or retaliate against him
for the collusion grievance that he
filed those are all gonna be gone the
clock gets reset to zero and he claims
he ever could have made against the NFL
will be extinguished and waived forever
the moment he signs the agreement and
gets his settlement from the NFL that
doesn't mean he won't be available to
make claims about things again happen
going forward but at least for now
anything that could have been claimed by
Reid is gone and most specifically the
thing that he complained about so often
the idea that the NFL was targeting him
for random PE D testing over and above
what the numbers should have been that
as a practical matter is over and done
and after this video ends we'll never
hear anything more about that issue ever
again
[Music]
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports